-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I'm hanging out with the amazing
Shaquille O'Neal.
Now, Shaq,
you're a man of many talents,
so I wanted to put your
impression skills to the test.
It is time
for "Guess the Impression."
♪♪
-♪ Guess the impression ♪
♪ Guess the impression ♪
-Why this?
Why are you doing this?
-Is this what this thing is?
My family would not
let me open this box.
I thought it was a gift.
I tried to open it,
they tackled me.
"No!
Jimmy said don't open the box!"
So now I can open
this little box?
-Yes, you can open that box.
-Geez, thank you.
-Yeah, it's not a gift.
It's part of the game.
In front of --
-Oh, it's a game.
-So, it's a stack of cards
with celebrities' names on them.
-Okay.
-On your turn, you draw a card
and have to do an impression
of whoever it is on the card
and try to get
the other person to guess.
And you want to other player
to guess as many as possible
before the timer runs out.
-Okay. Ready?
-Yep. You go first.
Ready, set, go.
♪ You ain't nothing
but a hound dog ♪
-Elvis Presley.
[ Bell dings ]
-Okay. That's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
"Oh, Jimmy,
you understand it's me?
Ah! I got that shmoney,
I got that shmoney.
I got the --
I got the red bottoms on.
-Oh, Cardi B, Cardi B.
[ Bell dings ]
-Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, uh...
"Yeah, baby.
Groovy, baby."
-Mike Myer-- Austin powers.
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes, pretty good.
Pretty good.
I can't do that one.
Uh, "This is terrible, Jimmy --
Jimmy Fallon.
That's terrible!"
-Charles Barkley!
Charles Barkley!
-Yes, it is.
Yes, it is.
Okay.
"Are you gagging, little baby?
Is Shaq making you gag,
little baby?"
-[ Laughing ]
Kevin Hart!
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes.
[ Both laugh ]
-"I did not have sexual
relations with that woman."
-Bill Clinton!
[ Bell dings ]
-Okay.
-One second.
There you go.
That's good, though.
We did well.
Shaq, 6.
-I'm able to do it.
-Six.
That might be a record.
You got to guess as many.
We got to beat 6.
-Okay.
All right, here we go.
And ready, set, go.
Uh...
"Uh, Michelle!
Uh, yes, we can."
-Obama, Obama, Obama.
-Yeah.
"Hey, Mickey, how you doing?"
-Sylvester Stallone,
Sylvester Stallone!
-Yeah.
Uh, uh, um...
Oh, "Elliott.
Reese's Pieces."
-E.T. phone home.
E.T. phone home.
-Yeah! There you go.
Uh, uh, uh...
Oh -- "You can't see me!"
-John Cena, John Cena.
-Yeah.
I gave a little extra Spock
in that one. Sorry.
Oh. Oh, okay.
Ready for this?
"All right.
Let's meditate
and then run
the triangle offense."
-Phil Jackson.
[ Bell dings ]
-Uh...
♪ Eating spaghetti
with Dave Brigetti ♪
♪ Play for the Yankees ♪
♪ Spanky's my favorite
Little Rascal [bleep] ♪
-Uh...
The dude from --
That's New Jersey.
Pauly D.
[ Buzzer ]
-♪ Ma's spaghetti ♪
♪ I'm sweatin', ready,
heavy, settee ♪
Hey, all right, 5-6, 5-6.
That was Eminem.
I was doing Eminem but terrible.
I didn't want to do
his real lyrics.
For this last round,
we're gonna see how many
we can get together.
We'll take turns drawing cards
and guessing.
You draw first.
On your mark, get set, go.
-"Can you tell
what I'm cooking, Kevin Hart?"
-Oh!
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
-That's it.
-Oh, "Uh, uh, uh...
Debra, everybody loves me."
Uh, uh...
No, what are you doing? No."
-Pass.
-Pass. That was Ray Romano.
You go.
-Oh.
-"Can I do that?"
-Urkel.
-Yes.
-"You are so tall.
You are one of the most tallest
people I've ever seen."
-Woody Allen.
-No, close.
But, no -- what, what are you --
My grandfather had this watch.
-Oh, I know his name, but --
Pass. I know his name.
-Christopher Walken.
You go.
-Yes, Christopher Walken.
-"For shizzle --
For shizzle my nizzle, Jimmy.
You wanna hit some of this?"
-It's not Bootsy Collins,
so I'm gonna say Snoop Dogg.
-Yes, it is.
♪ Whenever, whenever,
whenever, whenever ♪
-Shakira, Shakira.
-Yes!
-We'll get a point for Shakira.
All right, buddy.
That's it.
That was it right there.
We did it.
That's it.
You're 10 out of 10.
Shaquille O'Neal, everybody.